Тричі на тиждень лікар Ґергард Траберт
приїжджає в центр Майнца, щоб надати безкоштовну медичну допомогу безпритульним.
- Важливо заступитися за людей, які потрапили в біду. В цілому світі.
Довелося лікарю побувати і в Сирії.
Коли ситуація у виснаженій громадянською війною країні стала критичною,
він поручився за юних сирійців і організував їхній переїзд у Німеччину.
Подалі від війни.
- Їм погрожували: "Якщо ти не воюватимеш з нами за "Ісламську державу"
або на боці Асада, ми розстріляємо тебе або кинемо до в'язниці.
Дати людині можливість жити в безпеці -
це етичний, гуманістичний борг.
Один із вісьмох біженців, яких Траберт перевіз у ФРН, - Гергіс Бахо.
Молодий сирієць каже, що до кінця життя буде вдячний німецькому лікарю.
- У нас там війна.
Я не можу залишатися там.
Але проблема в тому, що нині німецькі чиновники
виставили Траберту рахунок загалом на 160 тисяч євро,
хоча всіх сирійців, якими опікувався лікар,
офіційно визнали біженцями.
- Якщо хтось не отримає статусу біженця, я нестиму ризики
і тоді буду за нього відповідати. В іншому ж разі
я маю нести фінансову відповідальність,
доки людину не визнають біженцем.
Однак після змін до міграційного закону німці,
які взяли біженців на поруки, мають до трьох років
платити за їхнє утримання.
Байдуже, надали їм офіційний статус чи ні.
Після численних протестів і скарг нині уряд Німеччини
намагається знайти рішення,
тому з таких громадян, як Ґергард Траберт,
виплат поки не вимагатимуть, запевнили в Берліні.
Тим часом Траберт отримав ще один рахунок на майже 14.000 євро,
в якому сказано: якщо не заплатите, будуть санкції від органів влади.
DW  з'ясувала, що подібні погрози є чиновницькою помилкою.
Проте впевненості в майбутньому нинішня ситуація Траберту не додає.
- Я б і тепер вчинив так само.
Мені здається, це мій, наш обов'язок:
бути поруч із тими, кому загрожує небезпека, кого пригнічують.
Ґергард Траберт сподівається, що йому та іншим,
хто поручився за біженців, в майбутньому все ж не доведеться платити.